salut c'est moi une petit spirou
c'est mes copains à la dune et à boire
debout le mouiller on adore l'école
plate et un diamètre de 12 mille
commencé mais met surtout pour faire des
bêtises
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas que du chanteur d'iron
maiden les sortir la bête qui est en toi
tu commences écoles de boom à la rentrée
prochaine
dix joueurs
comment vous imaginez vous quand vous
aurez 30 ans tu vas enfin suivre la voie
familiale
or chez les parents clic toujours pour
leurs enfants
[Musique]
je pourrai bien profiter des derniers
moments avec vous et si mon destin
c'était de faire un tour du monde mais
chrome c'est vachement mieux
j'ai fait des choses d'art et moi aussi
et tu vas avoir empêché de partir on
n'arrête pas un homme déterminé
tu peux aller je vais découvrir aussi
bien ta maman par les genêts autres
l'aident grand papy tenta j'ai reconnu
avoir le poids du tout c'est pourquoi
colette mon avenir je vois tes voyages
lointains ou du minerai jamais fait a
dit oui pour le tour du monde j'espère
jusqu'à mes parents sont d'accord et
c'est un bon français je vois des
contrées exotiques je crois que spirou à
faire une fugue
je viens juste de le creusot la valise
voir des prêts quand des voyous des durs
à cuire
je vois une belle différence et
rugissant
[Musique]
face au vertigineux
faites moi confiance dans les chiffres
la retrouver cette pomme de moules mon
embrayage est pas dans son assiette
[Musique]